[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
6 place de la république à mulhouse
je suis sûr que dans cette salle cette
adresse vous dit quelque chose
et oui le café molle lieux emblématiques
de mulhouse et bien aujourd'hui je suis
venu vous raconter ma vérité concernant
ce lieu je suis né un 13 mai 1973 à
paris
je passe ma petite enfance à chassieu
près de lyon avec mon frère gilles et
mes parents et d été
avec gilles nous passons des vacances à
menthonnex sous clairement un petit
village en haute savoie
chez mon grand père ernest maréchal
ferrant et forgeron et ma grand mère
henriette alors que je viens d'une
famille plutôt de t&e mon grand père lui
est un fabuleux conteur d'histoires est
là assis sur son banc double il me
raconte des récits de forges
vous savez le forgeron personnages
emblématiques important dans les
campagnes le forgeron qui sait pétrir le
métal et faire chanter l'enclume
beaucoup de métiers dépend des du
forgeron le charron le paysan le
menuisier et mon grand-père m'invite
dans son atelier allez vous y emmène une
petite minute avec moi dans la forge
il y a le foyer alimentée par le charbon
il y à la haute il y a le souffle est en
cuir qui permet d'alimenter le feu il y
un bac avec de l'eau froide pour
refroidir le métal est bien entendu il
n'ya l'enclume et le marteau et là mon
grand père depuis tout petit me disait
céline il faut savoir se forcer sourire
même dans les moments difficiles
tu attires ainsi la joie et la bonne
humeur en 1983 j'ai dix ans mon père est
muté pour son travail à madrid alors
j'apprends l'espagnol et le flamengo
la sévillane à quelques années plus tard
adolescente c'est un peu plus loin que
mon père est muté pour son travail à
buenos aires en argentine
alors là on ne parle plus l'espagnol
clinton a fait un espagnol as mais on
parle l'espagnol ou plutôt le portillon
à buenos aires vous voulez un exemple un
abricot c'est bizarre non en espagne on
dit al malik ok
et à buenos aires on dit damasco alors
c'est plus flou même cool que je danse
mais j'essaye les rudiments du tango les
années passent mais ce qui ne change pas
c'est que j'aime passer des moments
privilégiés
l'un assise sur le banc bleu de mon
grand père
et lui qui disait ne même pas avoir son
certificat d'études
et bien cet homme est un homme d'une
intelligence d'une humilité qui sait
décoder le ch des choses et les et le
monde quand ernest souris rien ne vient
être ni compliqué tout prend une autre
dimension
je grandis je suis admise la science
politique et j'apprécie toujours autant
les voyages parmi les voyages ven cité
un un voyage en terre mapuche au chili
où je passe quelques semaines dans une
famille mapuche et là je me rends compte
que finalement au premier abord mais
nous sommes tous d'étranges étrangers
dans le regard de l'autre
mais s'il ya bien quelque chose qui est
un vrai facteur de rapprochement et de
lien social c'est bien le sourire
une fois les études supérieures terminé
en france je ne rêve que d'une chose
c'est de retourner en amérique latine
mais cette fois non pas pour y voyager
mais pour y travailler
c'est ce que je vais faire je vais
travailler pour des entreprises
françaises dans les achats le marketing
et c'est en argentine que je vais
rencontrer celui qui va devenir mon mari
et le père de mes enfants je vais y
passer presque dix ans
je savoure les belles choses de ce pays
comme les choses plus compliquées et
entre autres en 2001 avec mon mari nous
allons vivre du jour au lendemain une
dévaluation
à l'époque il y avait une parité entre
le peso la monnaie locale et le dollar
du jour au lendemain il fallait 4 pesos
pour avoir un dollar vont s'ensuivre le
gel des comptes bancaires et va arriver
un phénomène qui est connu aussi dans
d'autres pays en espagnol en appel sa
losc à saint lô la source en français on
appelle ça les concerts de casseroles
phénomène populaire on manifeste contre
la dureté la cherté de la vie
face à cette débâcle économique social
avec une insécurité grandissante nous
décidons avec mon mari de revenir en
france avec maya aussi notre fille née à
buenos aires en septembre 2003 ma ya un
an
nous revenons en france et quelques mois
plus tard c'est ernest lui qui s'en va
il est décédé à l'âge de 93 ans
c'est étrange un jeu le croyait
éternelle et puis avec mon mari
maya puis mathias qui va naître en
franche comté
nous faisons nous avons plusieurs
expériences professionnelles entre
autres moi c'est en franche comté que je
monte mon activité d'indépendant dans la
formation pour adultes et le coaching et
puis mon mari a très envie que nous
crions notre notre entreprise pour faire
bref après plusieurs recherches nous
tombons sur un concept de brasserie
contemporaine après une étude de marché
nous atterrissons à mulhouse
ni mon mari ni moi sommes alsacien
d'ailleurs certains nous le font
rappeler que deux étrangers n'ont pas
grand chose à faire dans une scène où
reprendre ce lieu emblématique vous pour
vous rappeler la première image 6 place
de la république à mulhouse
alors petit à petit on cherche dans le
dans l'environnement mulhousien à faire
notre place ont créé différents
événements nous avons une terrasse qui
attire du monde
le chiffre d'affaires est là mais le
défi reste de trouver une stabilité
financière le loyer est important nous
avons fait un prêt énorme
et puis vous savez le diable se niche
dans les détails il faut se rendre à
l'évidence et c'est là le dépôt de bilan
est là et bien en quelques mois je vais
vivre la crise des 3 dès que certains
entrepreneurs malheureusement
connaissent le premier des sept dépôts
de bilan comme je vous le disais nous
sommes en 2015
cette année nous sommes 60 3008 à vivre
une défaillance d'entreprise le deuxième
d c'est le divorce
nous sommes l'année de mon divorce
128000 43 à rompre un engagement que
l'on croyait à vie pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
et puis va s'en suivre le troisième d
alors moi je l'appelle la déconfiture
ses émotions bien bien ratatiner parce
que je n'ai jamais prononcé le mot
dépression il faut savoir qu'en france
une personne sur cinq vivra un moment de
sa vie
un épisode qui peut ressembler un
épisode dépressif et le fond est bien
c'est que suite à ces 3d vont s'ensuivre
encore d'autres des d'autres dimensions
là le prochain décès le départ du papa
de mes enfants en 2017 qui préfèrent
fuir cette situation est retournée dans
son pays d'origine alors vont s'ensuivre
vous l'imaginez les déchirures
familiales et puis des dettes
j'ai eu le malheur d'être caution
solidaire d'un emprunt le désarroi pour
ne pas parler de désespoir en tout cas
en peu de temps je dois faire le deuil
de beaucoup de choses
le deuil de jeu ce que je croyais
finalement un parcours plutôt linéaire
élise quoi hein
la réussite d'un couple la réussite
d'une famille et puis la réussite d'une
entreprise alors la trouille de la
dégringolade s'installe la dégringolade
de coin la dégringolade d'avoir perdu
son affaire d'avoir perdu son couple la
trouille de finalement aussi perdre sa
dignité ou la confiance en soi
alors je fais quoi j'organise l'anonymat
de mon désespoir je me fais petit
à la question comment ça va c'est ligne
je dis ça va aux propos parfois
maladroit du style ma pauvre j'aimerais
pas être à ta place je pense éloignés
et puis le pire c'est que je suis
caution solidaire et mon appartement
risque d'être saisi
d'ailleurs un jour je fais la
connaissance d'un huissier de justice
qui sonne à la porte
alors vous avez mears vous avez compté
c'est pas trois aimé une bonne dizaine
de d'ela
et pour autant je devienne résiliente
vous allez me dire quoi vous n'êtes pas
cédé 3 d autres wap et la pensée
positive permanente nantes
les choses ne sont jamais aussi simples
non mais je crois que je décide de ne
pas dégringoler et je décide d'insuffler
finalement l'héritage de mon grand père
qui me disait céline il faut savoir se
forcer à sourire
même dans les moments difficiles et tu
attires ainsi la joie et la bonne humeur
alors je fais quoi
je chausse mes baskets je découvre le
running d'ailleurs ce qui me permettra
de retrouver l'amour ça c'est pas mal et
puis
je me dis que la faillite n'est pas
honteuse que derrière chacun d'entre
nous derrière chaque chose il ya des
failles jeu j'avance
constate que en effet les joyeux les
honnêtes ne triomphe pas toujours mais
je continue à insuffler cet héritage de
mon grand père je m'entoure aussi de
ceux qui comme moi pensent que face à
l'adversité on peut toujours porter un
regard sur ce que l'on a sur ce que l'on
sur ce que l'on aime et non pas sur ce
que l'on a plus et puis je continuer à
m'investir dans mon métier que j'aime
beaucoup la formation pour adultes et le
coaching
d'ailleurs je me découvre aussi
peut-être cette acuité à décoder les
autres et leurs failles alors bleus à
l'âme et du rayon au coeur accueillir
simplement les événements lâcher du lest
se débarrasser de ce foutu diktat du
bonheur à tout prix se désencombrer d
amertume
dégommer le pessimisme retrouvez le défi
de la joie simple et imparfaite cueillir
son bonheur dans le lien à l'autre
voilà mon fil conducteur ma vérité alors
l'enseignement de mon grand père s'il y
en avait un
c'est que le sourire en plus beau plus
aimable et moi je rajouterais plus
résilient le sourire n'est pas dupe
évidemment il ne permet pas de tout
résoudre mais il renforce notre
confiance en nous ou en tout cas notre
capacité de rebond
et puis le sourire est un remède c'est
un anti stress
en plus il paraît que ça ferait bouger
jusqu'à 40 de muscles du visage alors
donc et vous savez la même derrière vos
masques
votre sourire il est contagieux alors il
est véritablement troublant cet après
midi de vous raconter la vérité de mon
intimité concernant cette histoire avec
mulhouse et et avec mon grand père
ernest sacré gaillard sacré bonhomme
d'ailleurs il n'est pas mort ernest il
est tout simplement devenu invisible à
l'oeil mais si présent dans mon histoire
je lui suis loyal éternellement
d'ailleurs je vous remercie aujourd'hui
de médée d'une manière ou d'une autre à
lui rendre hommage
alors s'il y avait je sais pas peut-être
peut-être une seule chose à retenir de
mon récit
et bien c'est que face à l'adversité
le sourire est le début de la solution
merci
[Applaudissements]